we spent several hours testing and
breaking down aftermarket ps4
controllers here at GameSpot in hopes of
finding the best one and we got our
hands on four of them the Razer eyes you
make on revolution scuff infinity for PS
Pro and scuff impact so which one is the
best the answer really depends on two
factors the features you want and how
much you're willing to spend let's start
with some basics do you absolutely need
your controller to be Wireless if so you
probably won't want the rise you our
revolution since both only work when
they're wired they're designed with
competitive play in mind so it's
understandable why despite being the
bulkiest the riser is the most
comfortable to hold the scuff infinity
for PS pro is identical to the DualShock
4 while the impact closely resembles the
xbox controller and both come with
rubbery grips on the handles the
revolution has a nice chalky grip but
the trigger shape and the trigger
placement hamper its ergonomics with
that said the revolution had the least
desirable triggers and unfortunately it
can be a deal-breaker
they're far too stiff and take on an
awkward shape that messes with natural
hand positioning the riser stands above
the rest
since l2 and r2 are effortless to pull
and there are optional trigger stops to
shorten the throw scuffs controllers
look and feel similar to the DualShock 4
though you can lighten the resistance
adjust the trigger stops and swap in
extended trigger caps and what's a
premium controller without extra buttons
or paddles all four controllers offer
programmable buttons on the back end to
help keep your thumbs on the sticks at
all times the revolution is the best if
you only need two extra buttons the
outer buttons are placed perfectly while
the innermost ones are kind of hard to
use the riser works wonderfully as well
with the two triggers on the back and
two extra bumpers on top which all feel
tactile similar to mouse clicks scuffs
paddles weren't bad at all but they felt
the least natural to use scuff and razor
allow you to program these buttons on
the fly while Nikon requires you to
connect to a PC and using software to
tweak the controllers functions but it's
worth noting that nay con lets you tweak
the finest details of your controller
input the only controller that really
improves upon the face buttons is the
rise you there's soft and tactile also
identical to clicking a mouse it takes a
little getting
- but it makes for the most responsive
buttons all 4 controllers have analog
sticks that felt better than the
DualShock 4 since they offered better
grip and fluid movement for precise
aiming the revolutions and Raichu sticks
are lighter to the touch and have a
consistent resistance if we want to get
picky we'd say that these have a slight
edge though we can't write off what
scuff offers especially since these have
the best grip if there's one thing that
could kill your interest in these
controllers it's their price each one
cost well over 100 US dollars and the
ratio and revolution are only available
in Sony EMEA markets us buyers will have
to consider the nebulous cost of
importing scuffs infinity for PS pro
starts at $130 and the impact at $140
and any add-ons will cost a bit more
what if the best ps4 controller was in
front of us all along if we're
accounting for price I'd say the
DualShock 4 is pretty cost effective it
doesn't do anything special but also
doesn't do anything wrong but if you're
willing to shell out the dough and
itching for something more I would
recommend the razor rise you it's a bit
disappointing that while each controller
has some amazing features and
improvements over the DualShock 4 none
of them nailed down everything we want
however one gripe we may have with one
controller may not affect you in the
slightest
what chances are you'll have to make
some compromises either way after all
it's up to you to decide what matters
most in your purchase if you want a more
detailed breakdown of each controller
check out our reviews on them I hope you
found this video helpful so give us a
thumbs up and if you want more videos
like this be sure to subscribe to
GameSpot thanks for watching
you